I called it and I don't think my question was very clear. I said to the cheek swab last week with
the requested new write frequencies and wasn't sure how long I should expect to wait for the new
frequencies. I already sent an email stating that I could get the new frequency files via flash drive
or even download them from an email or drop box if they're too large to save on money shipping
flash drive. Yeah, we can't help. One thing we can't do and we've never been able to do is to email
on the frequencies because they because of the way that a folder is you can't even if you put it
in a folder I could email then you have to download it you have to take that and put it in
that's really confusing. It's even harder to do. So if you feel comfortable in doing a flash drive
I'll just send the first one. So I don't know if you heard that answer and you have to feel comfortable
about putting it in the opportunity. And again the instructions are on the member side and write
course. I know you've done the flash drive before but the version 6.4 is different than the version 6.0
so that's what I will say. With version 6.4 it's very different how the program goes in to the
right program it won't go into the main body of the program. So in version 6.4 you have to click if
there's two more clicks you have to make. So you open program on the version 6.4 right now if you
just got a 6.4 on your computer if you open program you'll see all the right programs but you cannot
put a custom program in that folder. You have to go over to the left and click documents. There's
four little things you can click on. One of them is documents the second one down and then in documents
you'll open up that and there will be nothing in there. So you have to create a folder in that
called true right frequencies and then you put your custom folder in that. So anybody that has a
version 6.4 that I did that on understands that completely go yeah I know we have two more steps and
now anybody started with us recently they don't know that at one point in time there was two less steps
to get into their program. They understand that they have to open up the true right program,
get open program then go to documents then go to true right frequencies and then go to their program.
So 6.4 is different. So you feel comfortable doing that all you're setting the flash drive. If you're
confused at what I just said it is written down in the member site if you're like I was totally lost
that'd be better to send me your computer and I'll put it in. Either way just think about it look at
instructions and then either email let's say yep I feel good. Send me the flash drive and I'll do that.